To what extent do you believe that
discourse with moderate Muslims can lead
to reform of the ideology such that the
gap between Islamic and Western beliefs
can be bridged?
Well,
I guess we're going to find out about
that because that's one of the things I
want to do over the next couple of
years.
Um,
as far as I can tell,
there's only three states of being there
is tyranny,
there's slavery and there's negotiation
and you know,
tyranny,
tyranny and slavery are forms of war.
So we either enter into discourse and
hopefully with the moderate Muslims or
we're the tyrants or they're the tyrants
and we're the slaves,
or they're the slaves.
And then there's war.
And so we bloody well better have
discourse because war is what happens
when discourse fails.
And you know,
we actually,
in some ways,
we can't really go to war anymore
because we're so armed.
And increasingly that's also the case in
the Muslim world.
I mean,
look at Pakistan,
it's,
it's developing a pretty decent nuclear
arm.
Our movement of nuclear,
a deterrent,
let's say,
which is quite terrifying because
Pakistan is one unstable and dangerous
place.
But I mean,
what are you going to do?
You're going to go to war with people
who have hydrogen bombs.
It's like,
that's not gonna work out very well.
So we bloody well better learn to talk.
And so I'm hoping,
you know,
I'm doing this biblical series,
which some of you may be no,
but in parallel without,
I'm doing,
I want to do a very long series of
discussions with moderate Muslims,
theological,
philosophical,
political,
practical to see if the gap between
Islamic and western beliefs can be
bridged.
I better be able to be bridged because
we're on the same planet man.
And there's lots of both of us.
So,
um,
capitulation on either side,
it isn't going to work.
And,
and like blind ignorance of the,
of the dangers,
mutual dangers that our society's post
to one another.
I mean,
to the degree that Islam,
Islamic societies are functional
traditional societies,
they're threatened in that functional
traditionalism by radical western
technological and philosophical
revolution,
just like worth threatened as Westerners
ourselves by our own technological and
philosophical,
revolutionary nature discourse,
truthful discourse,
man.
That's,
that's the hope for the salvation of the
world.
And so hopefully we'll put it into
practice.
I've,
I've met a number of moderate Muslims
already in Canada who are extremely
interested in this sort of thing and
some in the u s as well.
And so I think that,
well,
you know,
it's worth a try,
man.
So.